no matter who your preferred candidate
is in the 2020 Democratic primary we
cannot deny at this point the reality of
a Bernie Sanders surge in the last three
weeks and the corresponding
establishment panic that is coming with
it equally can't be denied I've got
receipts for you coming up but let's
look at the whole picture starting with
the national polls in the national polls
Bernie Sanders represented by the light
blue line on your screen indicated by
the red arrow has been surging for weeks
and Bernie is now fewer than five points
behind Joe Biden in an average of recent
polls meanwhile Elizabeth Warren has
fallen off Joe Biden is mostly even over
the last period of time no one else is
doing much other than Pete Budaj edge is
down slightly Mike Bloomberg has been
gaining as I told you previously let's
now look at Iowa Iowa is the first state
to vote voting on Monday the Iowa
caucuses February third Bernie Sanders
climbing there from barely third place
to a three point two percentage point
lead over Joe Biden into first place in
an average of recent Iowa polling second
state to vote is New Hampshire where
Bernie Sanders was also in fourth place
some months ago but has now taken a
sizable lead 24 to 16 over Joe Biden
Biden just imploding in New Hampshire
while Elizabeth Warren just can't seem
to get any of her momentum from a few
months ago back now admittedly the third
and fourth states to vote in the primary
which are Nevada and South Carolina not
going Bernie's way but then we get to
March 3rd Super Tuesday where there are
two big prizes both of which are looking
quite solid for Bernie Sanders first
you've got California where Bernie is
now just slightly in the lead in an
average of recent polls twenty four
point three to twenty three ahead of Joe
Biden and then this is very interesting
in Texas Bernie certainly not winning in
an average of recent polls in Texas but
a very strong showing in the latest poll
a Texas lyceum poll where it is a
statistical tie for first there is a
poll out of Texas that has Biden 28
Bernie 26 that is a statistical tie
because of the
margin of error now what is the
establishment doing there panicking the
establishment has not yet put together a
coherent United plan to stop Bernie
there's discussion of could the
nomination be denied to Bernie at the
DNC that might be too brazen we're
seeing publications like the New York
Times run negative articles about
so-called Bernie Bros an article
criticizing Bernie's online supporters
David Fromm wrote an article in the
Atlantic claiming that Bernie Sanders
simply can't win there's a New York
magazine piece by Jonathan Chait saying
that a Bernie nomination would be quote
an act of insanity I have no idea what's
going to happen I don't know if Bernie
Sanders will be the nominee
I believe Elizabeth Warren is done okay
when I look at the numbers I see the
following Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders
are going to battle this out they are
both going to pull delegates from early
States remember as long as you get at
least 15 percent of the vote in these
primaries you get a corresponding
percentage of the delegates if you're
under 15 percent you get zero so
increasingly what we're going to see is
a lot of people get 0 you're gonna see a
lot of zeros for Amy Klobuchar and
Andrew yang and Tulsi and Pete Buddha
jej is even going to have some zeroes
Elizabeth Warren peaked almost tying Joe
Biden months ago and it's been a decline
since then so I believe at this point
that it is Biden versus Bernie with the
outside possibility of Michael Bloomberg
becoming a contender now why do I say
that Bloomberg is only in in fourth
place right now well if you look at
polling change over the last two months
Michael Bloomberg started with nothing
and he just bought his way in let's not
pretend that he did it based on the
issues
Bloomberg poured money in and he
surpassed you know Castro and Klobuchar
and Tulsi and yang and he even now is
taking over a puta judge for fourth
place so I believe that if anyone has a
momentum trajectory if he keeps pouring
money in it is possibly Michael
Bloomberg
you look at the the bedding you can look
at how people are betting on the
Democratic primary you will see that the
betting is Bernie followed by Biden
followed by followed by Michael
Bloomberg so what we do know is the
establishment is panicking about Bernie
I'm curious in the way that people get
curious about a car crash or something
horrible like I'm curious and scared
about what they're going to try over the
next few weeks and my question to you
today is what do you believe well look
to power question do you believe a
coherent single strategy will develop
from the Democratic establishment to
deny Bernie Sanders the nomination and
if you do what will its components be
okay let me know on Twitter I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman I know that the
David Pakman show audience is full of
curious and creative people who love
learning new things and bettering
themselves and that's why I'm so excited
to tell you about one of our sponsors
Skillshare the vibrant online learning
community that offers thousands of
classes on almost any topic you can
imagine and you'll get full access to
the entire library of classes for two
entire months free when you go to david
pakman.com slash skill all of the
classes are taught by experts in their
fields they've got classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design bookkeeping marketing personal
productivity doesn't even scratch the
surface I recently took a class about
photography if anybody follows me on
instagram you know that my photography
skills leave much to be desired and it
was great I got so much out of it and
hopefully you will see the fruits of me
taking that class reflected in my
Instagram pictures sooner than later
they have classes for every skill level
whether you're wanting to get better at
something you already have experience
with you want to learn something totally
new to you you set your own pace classes
are usually less than an hour long
they're divided up into bite-size
segments so you can easily fit them into
your schedule make 2020 a year where you
explore new skills deep in existing
passions get lost in creativity
Skillshare really makes it
than ever Skillshare memberships are
less than ten bucks a month and that
gives you access to the thousands of
classes they offer but everybody in the
David Pakman show audience gets a
Skillshare membership totally free for
two whole months just go to david
pakman.com slash skill that's david
pakman.com slash s ki ll